hey francis do you like entrepreneurs
not really what do you mean what do you
think we'd do at trigonometry annoying
people on the internet cause meltdowns
on twitter and destroy people with logic
and facts all right stop stealing my
catchphrases it's facts and logic i'm
just saying being an entrepreneur is
against my culture why would i work hard
when i could just lie on the beach in a
sombrero shouting
well for those of you who aren't
venezuelan you need to check out rob
moore the disruptive entrepreneur rob
moore has been an entrepreneur for 16
years he's built seven companies written
18 business and investing books and now
he helps creators start up scale ups and
anyone wanting to build assets income
and freedom for information education
and inspiration rob has reached millions
of people to be disruptive entrepreneurs
and turn their passion into their
profession as well as instant access to
rob's number one ranked disruptors
podcast with the world's most disruptive
guests and billionaires he's also giving
away a digital financial toolkit to help
you save half your salary and cost in a
year plus keynote talks on building
digital assets and multiple income
streams digitally go now to
bit.ly slash rob toolkit but be quick
because this isn't usually free it's all
at bit.ly
rob toolkit and you will then be
directed to the disrupters podcast plus
all this great info will help you
destroy people with
logic and facts
i give up
see a heart transplant is something that
you can't actually schedule so you would
have to know
when someone's gonna be dead and the
only way you can really know when
someone's gonna be dead to give that
heart
is to make them so
as humans
we don't want to believe that people are
capable of such things
there was this whole kind of process of
bringing china into the international
monetary system first it was most
favored nation status
then it became world trade organization
a session the us basically sponsored
china's entry without having
the usual requirements
they found
through looking at protocols very
carefully 71 instances in the published
literature where people had been killed
by heart extraction
[Music]
hello and welcome to a very special
episode of trigonometry on the road from
the usa i'm frances foster i'm
constantine and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people it doesn't get any
better than what we have for you today
we're here in new york recording with a
man we've been friends with for a long
time we're really looking forward to
this conversation he is the host of
american thought leaders on epoch times
where he is a senior editor yanya kalik
welcome to trigonometry oh it's
fantastic to be here with you guys and i
love that you use the word fascinating
as a the whole my whole audience knows i
use that way too much
well welcome to the place for
fascinating people and conversations jan
um
one of the things we wanted to talk to
you about is actually the reversal of
the conversation you and i have just had
for your show which is about the west
and you have a unique personal history
and epoch times as an organization that
has an interesting history that ties
into all of that so we normally begin
our interviews by asking the guests to
tell everybody who are you how are you
where you are what's been your journey
through life give us some of that how
are you where you are and how is the
organization that you work for where it
is i don't even know where to start we
could do several episodes on this
um
let's let's start here okay in the
my parents both grew up in communist
poland
born during the war and my mother in the
early 70s
she made this
decision that changed her life and
constantine you'll appreciate for sure
why
she was given the offer to join the
polish communist party
and she refused that offer
and after that her life was irrevocably
changed she lost her passport she lost
her privileges and she had made a
decision
that she was not going to have her
children in poland because
well it wasn't free right
so that that's a that's a little bit of
background we came to canada uh in the
70s in a roundabout way there's a whole
like fascinating story into how she got
her passport back there was a communist
official in the office where her aunt
worked that everybody of course knew it
was the the the communist functionary
that every one of these offices had
this guy loved to drink this hundred and
eighty proof alcohol that
that
aunt used to make called na lefka and he
basically they gave him a lot of nalevka
he signed off the papers my mother got
her passport and she was able to get out
to france
my father came out they got married in
paris landed in canada and i came out i
think a month after arrival or something
like this
and you know learned polish as a first
language
and i also learned a lot about well the
realities of
life under communism in some ways you
know in your book constantine you
mentioned at the very beginning you
mentioned how everything in the family
has to stay in the family and i grew up
like that but i didn't really fully
understand why because we were after all
growing up i was growing up in a free
country so that's a little bit of
background and what about the epoch
times right
um well
so the epoch times is very interesting
there's an immigrant element here right
um
so you're you're familiar with uh of
course your audience is hopefully
familiar what happened in china in 1989.
1989 was the uh june 4th the tianmen
square massacre
there was a whole huge student movement
around that okay and a lot of people
don't know that uh john tong who is our
uh the current leader of the epoch times
um he was part of that student movement
and after 89 he
basically left he got a scholarship to
georgia tech
and never went back and this is kind of
what a lot of them did that could do
that um
1999 rolls around and the chinese
communist party picks a new enemy you
know it was the students in 89 now this
is it's the falun gong spiritual
movement
70 to 100 million people by government
estimates are doing this practice
grassroots truth compassion tolerance
these are the principles people are
living by very self-directed very
serious about these things
the communist party feels like it's not
maybe in control like this is a group of
people that's bigger than it is there
were i think 70 million communist party
members at the time
jung zamin the dictator at the time
feels like you know there's there's a
lot of evidence that he's kind of
jealous of you know the sort of the
popularity of the group and so forth he
doesn't want something that that isn't
strictly communist and strictly
controlled hierarchically as you well
know how things work in that system
so basically decides we're going to
eradicate this group and to facilitate
that this is where media comes in right
they basically take the whole communist
propaganda media that they control and
they demonize these people and you know
with talking points straight out of
1930s nazi germany same type of stuff
these people are evil anyway i don't
need to i don't need to go into the
details the worst things you can say
to justify right as it always as it
always works john you know as in america
sees this
starts a website because he is in a free
country and he can tell the truth about
what's really happening and not have
hopefully he's thinking all these
western media just take the chinese
communist party talking points verbatim
and just regurgitate them right
and uh this little website in chinese it
started first in atlanta uh explodes you
know because there is no other place to
get this side of the story and as you
know this people want to know the truth
is very interesting that's at least my
my supposition people always want to try
to find it especially when it's in in
there isn't a lot of it to go around
so
that's how we started and you know
within i think by 2004 they kind of
really realized wow this there's there's
some there's an interest in this there's
a market for this let's do this in
english and then let's do this and
actually now i think we're in 21
different languages
um around the world and but english was
the second and then you know with a
little bit of time english grew up and
kind of eclipsed the chinese became kind
of the the dominant and i would say
since
well since maybe 2015
2016 we've kind of taken on a a new role
i think maybe in in western society
trying to tell the truth in a climate
where
there doesn't seem to be as much of an
interest in it as there once was which
is bizarre uh on one side like among the
media but on the other hand among the
sort of the populists so to speak
there's a great interest which has
actually fueled
our growth over time
i was going to say do you not find it
worrying jan there's the state of the
maiden stream media at the moment
i find it deeply deeply worrying and in
fact i find it somewhat embarrassing in
a way because you know i'm glad that
we're able to grow in this climate you
know in marketing you have this idea of
blue ocean
strategy strategy right go somewhere
where there's a wide open space
in the area of truth-seeking media
there's a wide open space it's kind of
bizarre there's so many that could step
into this because so many
of these media have just decided to to
be about narrative creation for lack of
a better
term and i i'm deeply concerned about it
and you know but but of course we'll
we'll take it and what why do you think
that is why do you think there's so many
people and corporations and
organizations who've abandoned
troop seeking media and are now into
narrative creation
there are many many answers
reasons i think to this question that
i've come across and frankly you know
through talking to people much smarter
than me on american thought leaders i've
i've learned a lot about this but i
think a significant part of it is is
that a lot of the people in the leg what
i i like to call the legacy media
are people that um have subscribed to
this you know for lack of a better term
woke
some people will call it neo-marxist
there's ev every term has its detractors
but this sort of worldview
um
more progressive worldview which is
frankly believes the the real ideologues
in it the real true believers believe
that reality is constructed by
perception by by these narratives so
you know why would you seek the truth if
there is no truth only it's only what
the narrative is so i i think that this
has um
infected for lack of a better term these
media with these even the people that
don't strictly believe that because i
think you have to be
you know a very specific sort of person
to really completely believe that but at
some level it influences the way these
media function dramatically and what
impact do you think that's had on
society and
particularly american society
many many impacts
maybe maybe give me a uh i can think of
like 15 different ways well the most
important ones what are the ones that
you can
actually see the most important ones the
most tangible effects well the the
biggest one is that
there seems to be
uh movement away from the idea that
there is some kind of objective truth
that we can all
you know basically
manage our collective existence around
right because that's a very important
thing to have right to have you know you
understand if i'm talking about let's
pick an uncontroversial term racism no
i'm kidding but but
racism means something very different to
the typical person who you know learned
it in school in the dictionary
definition and someone who is very often
in the legacy media it means something
very different right we were even
talking to we think the word means the
same thing it actually means something
different um we're at the point where
even some even the sciences so to see
people are saying things like well yeah
two plus two it doesn't necessarily
really equal four let's have a debate
about that
right i mean i'm just this that's a kind
of a glib example but this is a real
thing and there was i recall there was a
fields medal winner that was making the
argument that two plus two equals four
isn't quite
it's not quite that simple actually so
you we're kind of it creates a situation
where we're in this
kind of hazy cloud of what is truth what
is reality and it's kind of the the
social fabric in the process starts to
kind of you know
come apart a bit it's fraying you're
right and jan you talk about truth
seeking and one of the things that
strikes me out of the conversations you
and i have had and particularly with in
the context of epoch times we had a
historian on our show called giles judy
who talked about the history of uh
communism in in russia the gulags and
the way that all of these things were
being perceived in the west and one
thing he told me that even i didn't know
was that actually information was
leaking out of the soviet union about
what was happening and people in the
west were ignoring it
and one of the conversations you've been
really present to uncovering
is some of the awful things that are
happening in china
to which everyone in the west turns a
blind eye you won't hear about it on
mainstream media at all
which is anything from the organ
harvesting program that they have to the
falun gong which you mentioned and why
do you think we don't know about these
things in the west and don't seem to
care about those things in the west
uh another easy question right i'm
kidding
but um well again so that the answer is
has many pieces to it i think part of it
is ideological i think
that ameri many americans um you know
you mentioned it in your book the the
nuclear bomb was handed to stalin like
the
essentially the entire blueprints how
does that happen
right well i call it the west's love
affair with communism
right so i think that that is certainly
a part of it there's this sort of
attraction
um i remember in 2009 thomas friedman
you know premier new york times
columnist at the time had an op-ed which
made me turn red i rarely turn red
reading things but you know we should
america should adopt governance
practices with china it's so efficient
over there there are many many elements
recently i heard he kind of disagreed a
friend my friend lee smith interviewed
him again he said well maybe i wasn't
quite right there but um so there's this
it's it's very odd there's this in plus
you know i think these authoritarian
totalitarianism there's an attraction
there because well you get to control
things right and here in place in free
societies there's a lot less control
it's a lot harder to shift things the
way you would want to and so forth
that's one piece i mean another piece is
is um you know opportunism with china
specifically right
there's been a great interest in this
massive untapped market of now 1.3
billion people you've heard about this
again uh there was this for lack of a
better term kissinger doctrine um for
for many decades right there was this
belief
among american industry and government
if we don't if you don't get into china
the next guy the next big corporation
will get into china so you got to get in
there and you got to
get your piece of the pie of course it
doesn't doesn't matter that you have to
compromise
very fundamental things like hand over
your entire ip right intellectual
property in order to do that um
so so there's been this kind of rush to
get in there and in the process
you kind of you know forget about some
of the crazy things like in 89 we knew
what the chinese regime was capable of
we knew exactly we knew that it would
send in tanks
to mow down
unarmed students and we were happy to
work with a government like this i mean
this is i think this is a profound moral
problem right this is 1989. you know
between 1989 and now we built
um you know america i think the most but
the west built the world's biggest and
our most dangerous dictatorship in the
process
there has always been this idea that you
know that free trade was going to solve
everything globalization was going to
solve all these problems
why is it that china has opened up
economically
but they haven't opened up in
you could argue far more important ways
um because they were given
full license to open up economically
kind of
and while
have no accountability whatsoever in
order to be able to achieve that so you
know there was um
in the
90s right
and into the 2000s there was this whole
kind of process of bringing china into
the international monetary system first
it was most favored nation status right
then it became world trade organization
a session the u.s basically sponsored
china's entry without having
the usual requirements
in order to do so in other words to be
able to get away with this things they
get away at the wto still today
you know because
the chinese regime never had an
intention
of adopting the west western practices
or at least the good gov western good
governance practices it only had an
interest in accessing the monetary
system so that it could
you know make money hand over fists so
to speak and and build itself
hey francis do you believe in diversity
and inclusion of course i do my dating
history is filled with diversity and
inclusion i am nothing if not an equal
opportunities employer all your previous
partners do seem to be of the same sex
i'm not that inclusive but if you are
worried about the polarizing effect of
diversity and inclusion in workplaces
then you have to attend the
counterweight conference on liberal
approaches to diversity and inclusion
we've had people from counterweight on
this very show to talk about how this
can be achieved they're great people who
want to improve society counterweight
believe that there is a need for
diversity and inclusion that aims to
eliminate workplace racism and
discrimination through a liberal and
unifying lens the current way isn't
working and we need a less divisive
approach the speakers are also former
guests of ours including eric kaufman
they're also giving free access for a
very limited time to a huge variety of
resources showing how diversity and
inclusion can be done properly without
all the reactionary nonsense peddled by
those who shall not be named so if
you're interested in making your
workplace better for everyone then you
have to check out the counterweight
conference on liberal approaches to
diversity and inclusion we promise there
won't be any lectures with titles like
why painting your bathroom why is a
microaggression it's an online
conference on the 22nd to the 25th of
september go to cw dot h e y
s u m m i t dot com and use our code
trigger pod twenty at checkout for
twenty percent off an all access pass go
to
cw.heysummit.com and use our code
triggerpod20 at checkout for 20 off and
all access pass
talking about the things that we don't
know about china then
what should we know what should people
understand about this regime that we've
been doing business with what are some
of the things that have been happening
that
a lot of
a lot of outlets in the west are just
not covering
well okay so the obvious one is the
organ harvesting
you know i i call it murder for organs
industry
more commonly it's called the forced
organ harvesting
reality in china it's the only place in
the world where it's state
state-sanctioned uh if not state
directed you know there's some debate
about that among the people that are
studying this
um but to make a long story short well
actually i'll tell a bit of a story okay
i believe it was in 2006 or 2005 or 2006
and is an israeli transplant doctor
named jacob levy
um had a patient and israel has has a
policy where if you need to get a trans
life-saving transplant you can go out of
country the state pays for that okay
um he he his patient tells him i'm going
to china i'm going to get this
transplant heart transplant i'm going to
get it in two weeks and jakob is as a
transplanter by the way head of the
israeli transplant association also he's
shocked and stunned and he understands
immediately that there's no ethical way
that this could happen because see a
heart transplant is something that you
can't actually schedule because you
would have to know
when someone's going to be dead and the
only way you can really know when
someone's gonna be dead to give that
heart
is to make them so
okay so you know he's kind of stunned by
this the guy goes comes back
and basically he's got the transplant
later there's complications that's a
different story but jakob
takes the time and in a couple of years
the israeli parliament has adopted a law
that says if you go to china to get a
transplant we will not pay for it one of
the few countries to the state by the
way that's adopted such a law it's very
very interesting but this is at this
point we already knew that something
terrible is happening uh two canadian
human rights uh two canadian lawyers uh
uh david kilgore they called them the
two davids david colgrave madison they
actually looked at the body of evidence
that was available at the time in 2006
they found yes definitely there's an
industry in china the murder for organs
industry
and the most likely people that are
being used for it are the falun gong why
the falun gong why because they're
there's millions of them in the labor
camps
they're a group that's targeted for
eradication so it's easy much easier for
people to
do things like this right murder for
organs and so forth so and i remember i
interviewed david kilgore back in 2006
about this he had he had spoken with a
guy who had gone to china and got a
kidney transplant they had fitted him
with eight he had a rare antibody
condition they had fitted him with eight
separate kidneys on two separate trips
the eighth one was the one that took
because the basically the antibody
situation wasn't an issue for that one
so you can just imagine how many people
likely lost their lives along the way
to get to that one transplant
um
more recently okay and this is this is i
think what you could call the
the the best smoking gun evidence that
exists but yeah i'll go back to jakob
lavi him and a journalist uh uh matthew
robertson
they put they basically looked at all
these chinese officially published
chinese studies in medical journals and
they found
through looking at protocols very
carefully 71 instances in the published
literature where people had been killed
by heart extraction
okay the the cause of death was
certainly their heart removal of a heart
and they've just they published this in
the american journal of transplantation
recently so you know it's been this
quest so to speak since that time to try
to
convince people that this is really
something that's actually happening for
starters
and you know it's really only i think
this year that i i hear kind of broad
acceptance and there's been a lot of
hurdles give everybody a sense of the
scale of what's happening how many
people do you think are likely to have
gone through this i just had a
conversation with ethan goodman maybe a
couple of weeks ago ethan was
i think the
premier
field researcher on this issue he's
lived in falun gong communities and in
uyghur communities this shifted later by
the way into the uyghur communities as
another extremely vulnerable vulnerable
group to be
used for this practice but
um the the estimate a credible estimate
since about 2002 is 60 to 100 000
transplants a year
and then if you and then i said well
that would be could be more than a
million people and ethan said no no yeah
that's an overestimate because the
because of ecmo technology so ecmo
is a type of machine that allows you to
replace the heart and lungs it's often
used when people need very complicated
surgeries and they you know maybe around
those organs or something like this so
around 2007 2008 ecmo technology started
being used so you could conceivably
because this is important to know you
can only really transplant from a body
that's brain dead and body alive you
can't transplant from cadavers so it's
it it there's limited time frame right
this gives you apparently 24 according
to ethan another 24 hours so you could
do multiple transplants that match
tissue and and blood and all this all
this so ultimately his estimate and i
think and he's very conservative in his
estimates is about half a million people
but the thing that struck me was i was
looking at the black if you're familiar
with the black book of communism right
that chronicles the the
deaths of various communist regimes this
you know is
a significant just this organ harvesting
extreme let's take that million a 500
that role number of 500 000 people 500
000 people
killed four organs in china
is
a significant number in the list of the
black book alone never mind the great
leap forward never mind the cultural
revolution never mind you know what
happened in the soviet union so and is
it purely done for money or is it also a
way to control the population to start
instill fear in them so uh the china
tribunal which was done a couple of
years ago headed by sir jeffrey niece
who prosecuted a little bit on milo
civic you're probably familiar with him
um he did this sort of independent
assessment with all the available
evidence and they tested the question
they said definitely crimes against
humanity within a few weeks even before
they found definitely this is a crime
against humanity uh definitely these
people are targeted but this is the
weird this is the bizarre thing okay
like i can't i can't help but smile
just because it's so frankly
yeah it's it's hard to fathom right um
they said well
because of the in order to satisfy the
genocide concept you have to say well
these there's a specific interest in
destroying these people
right
um and and and they are being destroyed
through the policy but in the case of uh
falun gong and this organ harvesting
regime there is the profit motive so we
can't definitively establish genocide
because of the profit motive
and it's like you see you're laughing
and i laugh too but then you stopped you
you think to yourself oh my god
right we can't establish genocide
because of the profit motive so if
hitler had done the holocaust for money
that would have been okay basically
according to this way of thinking well
so you know i'll tell you something a
really interesting thing you know you're
you're aware that that i recently
produced the film finding manny right
about my my wife's father as a holocaust
survivor one of the things we both
discovered that we didn't fully grasp
until in that film you can kind of see
us coming to this relation is how
important to the nazi war effort were
the was the slave labor by the jews and
other people in the concentration camps
you keep you just think of the death
these things as purely death camps but
no this actually the labor they were
making panzer files there these are
these kind of single-use anti-tank
weapons all sorts of stuff right really
basic stuff but significant so there was
also a profit motive bizarrely they just
wanted to use it's it's such a twisted
all right jan so yeah i hear you on all
of that why don't we care
why do we not care
is it because
i'm always trying to understand where
people are coming from
is it that i an ordinary person when i
look at the situation you've told me
what's going on there's nothing i can do
about it
there's nothing i can do about it is
that why we don't care
do we not care because our media won't
tell us about it do we not care because
it requires confrontation with the other
major superpower in the world to deal it
with this
do we not care because it's not in our
economic interest not to care is it to
care rather
but why don't we care
okay and if this is another one of these
all of the above answers but i think the
i actually think the fundamental reason
is that
as humans
we don't want to believe that people are
capable of such things and i've come
across this in all sorts of like
actually you know jan karsky uh was this
polish nobleman crazy guy right during
world war ii he breaks into
a nazi concentration camp
masquerading as a ukrainian guard right
and basically you know sees what's
happening gets out gets to the uk gets
to america says they're killing people
in mass right and you know there's this
famous felix frankfurter a.g at the time
uh in the u.s um jewish
says you know something like
i'm not later when faced with the with
the reality right he says i'm not i was
i'm not saying i thought the young man
was lying i'm saying that i was unable
to believe him now that sounds like a
throwaway line by a politician maybe but
i actually think there's truth to it i
think we don't want to believe it many
many people and then of course if you're
a politician the moment that you invoke
genocide the moment you say wow there's
something like this happening that means
maybe you are accountable now you're
responsible for doing something what do
we do oh my god wait there the the the
you know our economic interests might be
endangered you know at this point
um so so i think that the answer is
multi-layered there's and and frankly i
do think that there's there's this
element among the elite class and this
is something that i've i didn't want to
believe until
recently
that maybe they some of them just don't
care about this about this type of thing
right and
do you not think as well it's look
it's very difficult and we you touched
on it to persuade people to go against
their own economic best interests
if you can turn a blind eye to it and
continue to make your business
profitable
why would you suddenly make your
business unprofitable
to talk about this issue it's very
convenient isn't it yeah i think i think
we're very good at rationalizing things
that he's human beings
absolutely
especially when our own interests are
involved right but that that is kind of
the the answer of saying you know you
don't really want to know because if you
knew then you might have to change your
life and that itself can be
uncomfortable never even if it isn't a
financial interest maybe it's just you
have to change the way you do things day
to day we're very you know we like to
we're
i think you know
humanity has a lot of manifestations but
part of it
we can be quite selfish yeah and moving
but not on but actually back to where we
started which is your family history and
your background what well obviously you
haven't written my book in immigrants
love let to the west this is something
i've thought about a lot
why do you do what you do why do you put
yourself out there why do you
uh
you know you're a man who believes in
what he does you do what you do for a
reason and i think that reason is very
much the same reason that i do what i do
and francis does what he does because
we've seen another world our families
come from that other world
and
we know
what the west is
and we are all troubled i think by the
attempts to paint the west or something
it's not
why do you do what you do why do you
stand up for what you would argue of
western values and why are they
important
this is a great question um you know
i mentioned that i had been reporting on
the organ harvesting
since 2006. i was very i was kind of
shocked that there was you'd think this
would be a front page story right with a
little bit of work there's a woman named
dd i'll just mention it because i think
it's worth it a woman named dd kristen
tatlow who from as far as i can tell
you know gave up her career to make sure
that this story was published in the
pages of the new york times which is you
know was much more influential at the
time still than than it is now but
um
i have to i have to admit you know i've
i've always been a little bit
um maybe off the beaten path in my
thinking
and i've always um
found myself in situations where i have
to make tough decisions that maybe don't
affect just me but maybe others as well
that are uncomfortable so i i guess it's
not i it
i i i believe in this pursuit of truth
i i truly believe in this pursuit of
truth and that finding
trying to find it of course i don't
presume to have a monopoly on it just to
be clear at all right but but pursuing
it as best you can checking your
assumptions
and everything else um that that
and sharing that with people that's
something that actually can help us
have a good productive and healthy
society for myself for my family
for for everybody i i truly believe in
that
um
and i'm you know knowing what communism
can do
um
i you know and my my family is
also all sides of my family have kind of
suffered at the hands of various
totalitarianisms the nazis and and you
know the soviets under soviet occupation
in poland
um i could feel extra an extra
uh need to to tell people understand
that we're definite that we're kind of
heading in a very dark direction if we
don't
get ourselves you know kind of in order
and starts realizing what it is that we
uh
what it is that when we might lose
if we adopt
these
you know
utopian
ideologies and sort of try to realize
them
and what evidence do you see that we're
moving in that direction
well i'll tell you something funny okay
i see i see i see a lot of evidence but
this is actually
if you if when i talk to
immigrants that come from those systems
the people and this is what's really
interesting
there's two groups
one is the group that left for reasons
related to freedom
like my mother okay
and then other is a group that left for
economic
reasons okay
the people that left for freedom
without a single exception and i've
talked to tens
of such people
they will tell you
wow this system that we came from is
manifesting among around us right now to
me that feels much more compelling
as evidence than a lot of statistics and
a lot of but there's there's a lot of
information out there that can show you
you know for example you know we talked
about in our interview freedom of speech
the erosion of freedom of speech is a
great
uh marker an indicator for lack of a
better term that that we're heading in a
very very dark direction but but but to
me it's the the kind of the for lack of
a better term lived experience
right
um of people that have come from these
systems and left for reasons related to
freedom and liberty and so forth like
yeah this is i i'm seeing it in front of
me this is
and this is something funny my parents
they both they don't really agree on a
lot of things right um but they're it's
for them independently it's an obvious
reality
and where they're living with that
they're not saying we're there that it's
heading in that direction and there's a
lot of science and why is it look and
my mother is venezuelan you know so i
saw communism come in gradually with
jairus
why is it it's such
how can i put this like
it seems to western people in particular
left-leaning
younger metropolitan types
it's a very persuasive kind of
system you see the kids with the che
guevara t-shirts
why is that it's a it's a
fascinating question because i think
it's been this way from the beginning
from the time that marx wrote the
communist manifesto there's been a love
affair with it and you know i don't know
how many times it's been tried like a
couple of dozen or something like that
right in every single instance that has
been tried it's definitely successful
it's done what it does best yes it's
done it's done what it said and then you
have the next people that are saying
let's yeah but it's never really been
tried
um
i
there's a couple of again a couple of
answers that and i don't have a
definitive answer to this by the way not
not by a long shot
but one i do feel it has
kind of
theological elements it's it it
functions i think like a replacement
religion for people
in a situation where you know in
nietzsche's words
god was
humans killed god right or not his exact
words but that's the idea like we kind
of
believed in
i guess the logical conclusion of the
enlightenment that all these things that
we can figure everything out
without
those the benefits of religion for lack
of spirituality lack of a better term
and and and but communism
allows for people to tell themselves
yes i'm actually you know
i'm a true materialist i'm you know and
i'm looking at things this way
but and i reject religion but actually i
think that that it functions that way i
think it functions like a replacement
religion there's a lot of evidence
around that i think so that that that's
one piece um
uh another piece is
so i think there's sort of an
attractiveness to it but there's also
been
you know a huge interest because america
has been
uh the us and and frankly western
countries have been so successful
there's been a specific interest
in injecting that system into
places like the us and canada and the uk
um
by people who who seek to
damage it or replace it um
we talked about yuri besmanoff you know
is perfect is the perfect example he
kind of explained how the soviets were
doing it for decades right so on on one
side it's attractive on the other side
there's a very dedicated effort i think
desmond off once said that 85
of the work or something some number
that high
that they were due that the that the
soviets security services were doing
overseas was around that around changing
the culture around demoralizing yeah
exactly so so the combination of those
two things
i think is creates a really
you know i guess difficult reality and
you know if bezmanoff is right that once
you get past through this demoralization
over decades it's very hard to convince
someone that they've been
brainwashed or or or you know
ideologically you sort of you know
changed
you can try to tell them any sort of
facts hey look here's the res look at
look at what happens when you're not
part of a uh when you're in a fatherless
family look at what look what you're
we'll look at your life life results how
they change statistically it's something
that everybody left wing right wing
think tanks agree uniformly fatherless
house households the children are
basically
highly disadvantaged no one wants to
talk about it or at least the people
that you know don't want to believe that
such things are important and of course
in communism
it's it's the state that's the father
and mother right it's not the parents so
and we and we saw that particularly with
i don't want to go into covert that much
but what i found interesting with covid
was particularly in the uk people
looking to the state to solve their
problems going well look this pandemic
is here what is the government going to
do about it yeah you know what can the
government do to solve the pandemic
i found that worrying deeply worrying
so you know you're basically saying that
as a society i mean as the west you're
talking about the uk i think the
phenomenon is similar in the u.s not for
everybody but certainly for a
significant group of people
there's this idea that somehow
the government has to provide for you
the government has to find the solutions
um
there's a whole other group of people in
america that find this whole concept
offensive right the idea is like you
want no what is it that ronald reagan
said something one of the most uh the
the most damaging things you can hear is
i'm from the government i'm here to help
i forget i forget exactly what he said
but something in this vein
it would seem to be a result of this
whole pro exactly the process that we
were just discussing because
you know you have
in in
communist society right the state
is
the giver of all right as the manager of
perception
it's the it basically is the provider of
everything it's it's all the good that
is in society comes from it all the bad
is from the nefarious opponents to it
and it believes likewise that that that
the reality that it whatever it tells
you is reality is what you must believe
and that that is the correct way to view
the world so
um
it's it i am i'm with you but that's
basically what i'm saying it's it's
stunning to me that there's so many
people saying that
um and we i would i would hope we we
have a we can robustly educate the next
generation to not think that way
we hope you're enjoying this incredible
interview did you know that you can ask
guests your questions that's right when
you join our local community not only
will you know who we're about to
interview you have the opportunity to
ask them your questions you have the
chance to ask jordan peterson the
co-founder of extinction rebellion nigel
farage douglas murray andrew doyle jeff
norco simon evans larry elder david
badill andrew sullivan megan kelly julia
hartley brewer lord nigel lawson brett
weinstein inaiya for larry niman dr
david nutt jimmy dore gad sad blair
white melissa chen trevor phillips
ayanne hersey ali glenn lowry bridgeford
i see jim rickards carl benjamin and so
many more plus we're about to interview
some of the biggest guests
in the world we can't name them just yet
but trust me they're huge
metaphorically speaking not just because
they're american our locals gives you
access to a great community of
like-minded people where you can share
memes and make new and problematic
friends you also get early access to
live shows and we're about to release
details of our tour so you'll want to
know about that as well
on the higher tiers you get monthly
supporter calls and the opportunity to
have a meal or a call with us click the
link below or go to
trigonometry.locals.com
and join the community that's
trigonometry.locals.com
we'll see you there
where is this going yen
there's a there's a big debate between
francis and i on this issue okay
because
i
because i'm naturally an optimistic
person and maybe because
there are a lot of us now talking about
these things um because trigonometry is
doing well and my book is doing well and
i sort of it's very tempting to think
that we're making progress and we're
turning things around and the pendulum
is the pendulum is slowing down and
maybe it will actually swing and then
actually what we need to worry about is
it will over correct another direction
as it always does you know that's where
my minds have been at francis the
eternal pessimist of course says very
differently he says this is just going
to get worse and worse
what do you say um okay
this is this is a tough question and i'm
i'm not of a single mind on it but i'll
tell you where i see
problems and where i see hope okay
um
i kind of i'm in the besmanoff camp that
once people have been
demoralized
okay that it's very tough
to get them to take things like even
reality in front of their face you know
seriously they have to kind of be
shocked into it
um somehow i that and i you know in
other interviews i've done i've i've
this this is this is a very difficult
problem a very difficult problem because
we have a whole generation that's saying
things like you know that finds
socialism attractive i mean not
everybody but it's like what is it 60 in
america i can't forget if the young
people is unbelievable
right um so that that's the one side on
the other hand
um you know the
and the other the other thing is that
essentially all the cultural
institutions have been
you know basically been seized all the
major cultures by by adherence or
somewhat adherence so perhaps some
cynically all cynical adherence and some
actual ideologues of this woke ideology
and that's deeply problematic
um similarly because all these other
people are you know sort of
being pushed into
um
if not agreeing believing they should
and the young people are the ones that
are of course the most impacted this way
that's one side the other side is i feel
like there is this element of the the
pan being overplayed
right you have for example you know i
was just that i was stunned okay in the
when we were watching the there's uh the
state of virginia
at an election
and education was a central issue in
that in there and basically the the the
the democratic opponent
literally said that he thinks the state
i mean to paraphrase that this
the parents shouldn't be have the final
say in the children's education that the
state should right and so this is it's a
weird platform
position to take
right and and just as i i don't know who
could who could argue that and so you
know um
we have this
situation where all these people that
for lack of a term just kind of
generally want to be left alone that the
most of population are not activists
they don't want to be active they want
they just want to be able to live their
lives have good
decent lives be successful enjoy time
with family whatever right like
basically all of this type of thing
those people
at some
scale now have been activated
democrat and republican in the u.s
basically of of different ideological
stripes and i think that's very
interesting because they realized this
is one of the silver linings of covid
there was all this remote education i've
heard the story
i could say more than a hundred times
not hundreds maybe but i was listening
to what my kid was learning remotely and
oh my god what
right
and and these people just have been
quote unquote radicalized activated to
stop
some of this stuff and then in the
process realized maybe that's the shock
right we're saying there has to be this
kind of shock to the system so
when when those when the people that
normally
uh don't
want to be involved get involved because
they feel like they have to it's gone
that far
that's where i actually see the hope i
don't see it coming from
you know the the intellectuals although
there could be certainly some guidance
from there like certainly reading a lot
of thomas soul uh you mentioned him at
our interview it would be incredibly
helpful to people very a lot of really
common sense basic stuff that
shockingly you know i if
six or seven years ago i didn't even
know who thomas soul was
right to give you
so
there's certainly a lot of learning we
can do that way but i think it's the
the the normal people for lack of a
better term the silent majority
sometimes it's called that people who
believe in common sense and also frankly
there's this other element i have to
mention right i think because we live in
an increasingly information economy
the the we call it the laptop class
there's all these people that live much
more in a virtual world that they can
kind of get away with not having to
fully grasp that there's
kind of a physical like how does the
food come to me well it arrives actually
it's not on amazon
right all of this exactly exactly so so
i think it's the people that are have to
do things with their hands that are you
know why was it truckers in canada that
were the ones that said
these mandates that's we can't we can't
accept this right why it's because it's
the people who have to face the
consequences of reality of really bad
policy right
so i think and that that's the silent
majority in it but i also think it's the
essentially the the the working class or
people that are doing things physically
the the reals versus the virtuals was
one i think ns lions described it that
way in a wonderful essay
um a while back i think that those
people becoming
awake
in the term that
i prefer
um
there's huge hope in that and i i like
to think that that that that we'll be
able to turn it around but i don't know
like i wouldn't sit here and make a
prediction well the reason i ask about
it you mentioned these real people i
think um
the last time that attempt was made
and inevitably whenever there's a
backlash against things it's never the
prettiest
version of of that what could have been
right it sort of looked a bit like
brexit and it looked a bit like trump
and what that seems to have done is
actually made
i don't know if it's made the problem
worse but it certainly made the debate
more heated
we didn't we didn't get to the places we
thought we'd get to where there was
better understanding we got to a place
where we're more polarized not less so
that to me would sort of i'm arguing
against myself here
that that to me is the
the thing i would question about what
you're saying because as the the sort of
the internet term would be normies start
to wake up uh
maybe the backlash will just be even
worse against them you know i'll look at
all these whatever names that get
attached to them they're they're doing
this thing again that they do
you know what i mean yes yeah i do i i
don't know i think
see
i think that
the people that believe
whether actually or cynically in
woke-ism again for lack of a better term
i think that they believe
certainly the the ideologues they
believe that this is the only way that
everybody should think this is part of
the reason for
uh the erosion of freedom of speech and
part of the reason why you you know you
can sort of enforce incredible minority
opinions
on a vast portion of the population
whether it's you know for example uh you
know biological males and women's sports
is a great example of something like
that like most people really think
that's a bad idea but somehow you know
in the popular consciousness whoa
right um
so i don't think it would go away like
the attraction
i've talked with many trump supporters
over the years
the the common theme is
why what was the attraction of trump
well actually a a lot of policy sort of
basic sort of more
what would have been considered you know
ten years ago centrist policy
but but the other part was he fights for
us he'll fight for this position right
there's this general sort of
dissatisfaction in the politicians of
the day that they simply aren't don't
don't are satisfied with the status quo
and won't go fight for these things
so i think
i i suspect the polarization
actually already exists inherently and
as long as
you know as long as things are going in
the direction that the
whoa ideologues
think is the correct direction there
doesn't need to be a lot of
you know animosity because everything's
going the right way but the moment that
it gets stopped then all hell breaks
loose but i think that's that that it's
that's kind of inevitable because if
there's if if if they belie truly
believe that there's only this one way
of looking at the world how can you
avoid that do you know do you know why i
think it's it's never going to stop and
the answer is in the name progressivism
they believe in constant progress and
not only do they believe in constant
progress even more terrifyingly they
believe in utopias
so if we carry on and constantly
progress we are going to reach nirvana
where everybody is equal
so why would they stop
i can't see any reason
well so you know
uh john mcwhorter has a
book that i thought was very very good i
think he's been on your show yeah yeah
um one of our favorite guests yeah he's
brilliant john
well so i mean his his approach is
as perhaps i don't know if he talked
about it because i haven't seen the
episode but is to well you know of
course we have to tolerate these people
but you just want to kind of move them
away from any levers of power
that that sounds like a like a you know
a reasonable approach because
an authoritarian response
or totalitarian response to all these
things isn't something that we can
really do without destroying ourselves
right in the process right so these are
these are these are very serious
difficult problems right if someone
believes
with fervor that
the society has to look this particular
way that's very devoid from any
semblance of reality how can you well
you want to help that person as best you
can but you don't want them to be making
policy right i mean that's i think
that's the
i i don't know if i've answered your
question yeah it's fine the the other
question i really wanted to ask and this
is particularly will they ever stop i
think i i don't think they will if if if
at the levers of power no yeah what do
we do with institutions institutions
that we used to respect for instance in
in my country the bbc
in in you know new york times over here
and so on and so forth
do you think these institutions can be
saved or do you think that we need just
to scrap them and start again they're
too far gone this is this is kind of a
set up for me i think
because like in a good way i mean i
don't
i think that
i'm a believer in this sense of very
much in a free market
right and so free market for media
um
let me qualify something
i think it's a very difficult situation
where
most
media that have a large megaphone are
saying the exact same thing and that
thing happens to be often just simply
not true that's a huge problem because
it creates a situation where a lot of
people in society are just
believe things that are just simply not
true right there isn't when there isn't
this desire at least strong impetus to
try to seek the truth because those
people a lot of people believe
that these narrative creating media are
actually truth-seeking media see there's
this there's that disconnect right um
i don't know we we can't
we what we can do is we can uh try to
stop supporting these institutions in
sort of structural ways like where the
you know the government actually
supports them in a lot of cases like in
canada the government is actually paying
a lot of money to these to the larger
media and you know you can see the
inherent problems with that i'm more in
favor of a free market where you can
have the epoch times
you know sort of in a level playing
field
uh same access to advertising same
access to
to
essentially the entire market not kind
of artificially
you know stopped because of you know
ideological disagreements
um and and let the let the best man win
right and i i because i'm a believer
that truth is something that humans
actually do seek and and there's an
inherent attraction to it and i think
that's the reason epoch times became so
powerful and and
and and uh attractive out of the
starting gate and that's why we've been
able to grow many times over over the
past few years because because people
recognize that and that's the feedback
we get from from our viewers all the
time so that's why i said it was kind of
a set up question like i don't i don't
think we should be scrapping anyone but
i do think what we should be doing
and is to try to create as level of
playing field as we can so people can
legitimately decide for themselves you
know what is this hey okay let me check
this media out is it is it
is it providing me with with what i need
i'm going to push back on that because
okay okay and i'll tell you why i
completely agree with you
everyone's great pushback right
i completely let me push back you said
everything right i agree with you there
is
one flaw in your argument okay which is
we think we're going to continue or we
don't
we think that the internet is going to
be fair
we think we're not going to get shadow
banned we think and we're already
suffering from it
so this idea is great but
well we we're also we're also suffering
from it obviously this is the reason i'm
saying i'd like to see the playing field
level you're saying how can we make sure
the playing field level well i can say
we can you know demand
legislation uh we can you know encourage
uh the election of of uh uh lawmakers
that will foster the kind of
legislations that will create a level
playing field do i think that's
difficult yeah yeah
i do
yeah um but i i do think we have to use
the democratic institutions to do it or
die trying like again i i i think that
we have to
and this is where you know some people
might disagree with me right but i think
this system
that i i've come to really appreciate
the american system right it's an and i
it's inherently inherently
slow
and it's in it was created i've come to
believe in such a way as to try to
prevent
any one group from assembling too much
power at once but the cost of that is
that things move slowly
that you know you
you you hear pack the court you hear all
these things all these things are kind
of difficult to actually accomplish
because of the structures because these
founding fathers you know basically
thought to themselves people are going
to try to amass massive amounts of power
and enforce their view on everybody else
let's create a system that actually
prevents that from happening it doesn't
matter who
right
so
yeah it's it's it's it's difficult but i
i kind of i have to believe that the the
institutions can be resilient to it
if we fight for it
right using these
let's say for lack of a bedroom good and
just tools at our disposal
that's a good note to finish up on jan
it's been an absolute pleasure uh to
speak with you and i think one of the
things that makes everything you said
more powerful for me we've see we've
just been at the epoch times offices
we've seen how many people are working
right and it shows me that it's possible
to create
big institutions that that can challenge
some of these narratives and what you're
doing is really valuable for that reason
as you know the last question we'll ask
you a couple of questions from our
supporters only for locals which only
they will see but before we do that uh
the last question we always ask is what
is the one thing we're not talking about
as a society that we really should be
you know you you of course you posed
this question to me i i think there are
many things of this nature but
i think
here he i've come to believe that humans
have an
intrinsic
interest in their nature
of being connected for the lack of a
better term with divinity with their
creator people think about it in
different ways
right
and to pretend that that's not the case
and this is a consequence of the you
know the enlightenment the amazing
products of the enlightenment i might
add right
um and this is something that matthias
desmond chronicles very well in his book
the psychology of totalitarianism which
i keep plugging because i think it's
such an important book he talks society
has become atomized
you know and just by nature of us
thinking of ourselves as being
just you know physical
entities as opposed to
spiritual entities connected to god or
divinity or again you know different
people across the world think about
these things differently so i to me
that is
a central piece of the conversation that
i don't see being had a lot
but i think is faster than foundational
to finding our way out of this because i
don't i personally don't think there's a
way out without people facing that and
trying to understand that connection
now you know people that
we three of us know mutually would i
think vehemently probably disagree with
that uh people who i respect deeply and
i've learned a lot from
but uh yeah that's what i think
yeah thank you so much for coming on the
show if people want to find you
online if people want to learn more
about the epoch times or american
thought leaders where can they go to
find these things well so
the epochtimes.com
is of course the main epoch times
website you can join us there um
american thought leaders is
on epoch tv if you type in epochtv.com
you'll you'll find american values and a
whole suite of other uh very interesting
shows including my film uh finding manny
a film that i made with my wife
about her uh holocaust survivor father
it's a that's i i'm plugging it a little
bit because i do think it's kind of a
bit of a miracle for us of a film first
attempt out of the blocks and just a
very important story
um
so that's yeah and american thought
leaders um you can also find us as a as
a podcast
on apple podcasts and so forth yeah
don't go anywhere because we're going to
ask you a couple of questions uh from
our local supporters but i should thank
thank you also for letting us use your
studio here at the epoch times we really
appreciate the time you've spent with us
today i hope people check out your work
with american thought leaders thank you
for being on the show and thank you guys
for watching and listening we will see
you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show all of
them go at 7pm uk time and for those of
you who like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
do you think the epoch times is getting
traction with their information on the
war being waged by china against the
west
or is there still a dominance of
ignorance out there
[Music]